( intro music )
( applause )
Thank you for coming
out tonight.
It's a great group.
And let's take a step
into my most favorite world,
away from the world of
human beings,
into the world of the jaguar.
I've been working on
big cats and other species
for over 30 years.
But nothing in the
tropical jungles
has ever made my hair
stand on end
like one particular sound.
( Jaguar growl )
This is the guttural growl
of the jaguar.
This is saying stay away.
You've wandered too close.
I've heard that sound
five times in my life.
And it's never gotten
any easier.
( audience laughter )
The oldest jaguar we have
on record
is that of the European jaguar.
In reaction to the
Pleistocene ice ages
started doing what we
now know is
a true characteristic
of jaguars.
In response to adversity,
in response to
environmental perturbations
the jaguar moves.
And it moves, and it moves.
Traveling thousands of miles
eventually
throughout the Pleistocene
scattering in all directions.
Now by the mid-Pleistocene
the European jaguar
went extinct.
The earliest evidence we have
of early man and
jaguars together
comes about
4,000 to 11,000 years ago
where skeletons of early man
and jaguars
are found in the same place.
In a cave in Texas
called Schultz Cave.
There were at least
12 civilizations
going from Mexico
into South America,
but one of the
earliest civilizations,
and where what I call
the Jaguar Cultural Corridor
was born
was among a group of people
called the Olmec.
One author who studied them
called them "jaguar psychotics".
( audience laughter )
What the Olmec did,
they actually would deform
the heads of their babies
in order to make them look
more like cats.
They believed that children born
with Down Syndrome
weren't anomalies
they were almost God-like.
They believed that
Down Syndromes children
looked like those cats.
And were a cross
between a female,
a human female mating with
a male jaguar.
Following the Olmecs,
the Maya carried jaguar
iconography to new heights.
Always depicting jaguars
never as just an animal,
always as something more.
Not just animal-human
but beyond that.
Jaguars controlled the
world that the humans
couldn't control.
And if people wanted to control
the wild
they had to somehow
do it through jaguars,
become one with the jaguar.
This was taken to its heights
with jaguar shamans.
And one of the things
that the jaguar shamans
always sought to get,
to absorb were the eyes
of the jaguar.
The eyes of a jaguar
were believed to be able to see
into the spirit world.
Jaguars guarded the underworld,
jaguars were a link to the
spirit world.
The modern day Maya
still believe
if you wanted to see ghosts,
you-- animals can see ghosts,
you go and take
tears from an animal,
rub your finger in an
animal's eyes
and then rub it on your eyes,
it's one of the most
unhealthy practices
( audience laughter )
in the world
and you can see, see ghosts.
Now all of this came to
an abrupt end
in the 15th century
when the Spanish
and Portuguese colonists
came and conquered the
New World.
Now what the Spanish
also brought with them
were just big, dumb
hunks of meat on a platter...
( audience laughter )
cattle.
And their version
of cattle management
was to allow large numbers
of cattle
to free range into wild areas.
The jaguar had no idea
what this animal was
other than a big chunk of meat
that stood there
as the jaguar swatted it and
knocked it down.
( audience laughter )
So, what happened,
jaguars were not seen
as semi-deities now anymore.
They were seen as vermin,
seen as pests.
And the only way
to get rid of them
was to kill them.
And you value them as trophies.
What really happened,
which almost destroyed
the jaguar
was the fashion industry.
In the 1960's,
interestingly
in the 1960's
Jackie Kennedy came out wearing
a leopard skin coat.
In fact the man who created it
for her,
Oleg Cassini later said
it was one of the worst things
he ever did in his life.
Because he had no idea
what it would lead to.
That spurred a fashion industry
of spotted cat coats.
Jaguars were becoming wiped out,
as well as other spotted cats.
That's a real leopard skin
around that dog by the way.
What happened with this terrible
trade in spotted cat coats
is that all the governments
started to set up
new protected areas,
started passing new laws,
started banning jaguar hunting,
trade in jaguar skins.
So this was good
but now the jaguar
had to come back.
Okay,
then a little boy named Alan
steps into the scene
( audience laughter )
who knew nothing about what
was happening with the jaguars
and other spotted cats.
I was a young man
but I had been born
with a debilitating stutter.
A really horrible stutter
to where I couldn't speak.
It was called,
by the people at the time
it was called "frozen mouth".
They didn't know
what to do with me
in the New York City
school systems,
they put me into
"special classes".
They didn't know about
dyslexia or ADHD or many things.
I just shut down.
So I didn't talk to any adults,
which made them think
I was even more disturbed.
But what I could do
is I could talk to animals.
I still stuttered,
now we know stuttering
is not purely psychological,
it's genetic.
But I still stuttered
but I could,
I could express myself,
there was no expectation,
no judging,
no speed-up, slow-down,
no calm down or
finishing words for me,
or anything like that.
So, I could--
they became my life,
they became my friends.
And when I had bad weeks
at school,
and there were many,
because back then there weren't
these things against bullying
and I was in a lot of fights.
And I was always
in the principal's office.
When there was a really bad
day at school
or a bad week,
my father would take me
to the Bronx Zoo.
And my favorite place
at the Bronx Zoo
was what I called the
"Big Cat House".
Cage after cage after cage,
concrete cage of lions, tigers,
one lone jaguar.
And I knew as a kid, it was
really obvious to me as a kid,
here these really big, strong,
healthy, normal animals
and they're locked inside
these jails,
inside these cages,
by human beings
who they could kill instantly.
And the reason was
because they didn't
have a voice.
They didn't have a human voice.
Imagine even today
if animals had a human voice
how we would treat them.
How many animals would we keep
even in our nice zoos,
nice enclosures,
if they actually said,
"Please, I don't
want to be here."
Or, "Look, please,
stop feeding me that same food
you're feeding me,
it's really terrible."
How would we treat animals
if-- and that's the
only difference.
They can speak,
they communicate,
we all know that.
But they don't have a
human voice.
They were me, I was them.
They became my haven.
There was one lone jaguar.
This is a picture from
my children's book.
And I would always spend time
with that lone jaguar
because that jaguar,
while all the other cats
charged and growled and
made vocalizations,
that jaguar sat back,
and just watched people
as if the people were in a cage
and it was in charge.
And I would stand there
and talk to it.
And I would promise that jaguar
and I had no idea
what I was promising.
I was a very young child
I had no idea what there
was in the greater world.
All I knew was
my world was horrible.
And I would promise him
"if I ever got a voice
I would be the voice
for the animals."
Now I had no idea
what that meant.
And it wasn't even about
the jaguars
as much as it was about me.
But I did make that promise
every single time I stood by
the jaguar's cage
or the tiger's cage.
And I never forgot that promise.
Fast forward
20-- how many years,
I was about seven.
Fast forward about 15 years
or so in the future,
went to graduate school,
studied eco--
new courses called ecology
and animal ecology,
wildlife biology,
and I meet my mentor
George Schaller.
I end up being sent by
George Schaller
to this newly independent
country called Belize
in 1981.
In order to try to see
why there are jaguars
being actually hit
on the one dirt road
through the entire country.
Then when that worked out
he said, "Would you like to
go back for a few years
and actually try to
capture them,
study them, radio-collar them?
Do what nobody has ever done
in the rainforest habitat."
And I said, "Absolutely."
I had no idea
how I'd catch jaguars.
( audience laughter )
I had no idea
at first where even Belize was
when he first told me.
So I went down.
Now catching jaguars
wasn't easy.
I didn't know how at first.
The first time I built
wooden traps two-by-fours,
I actually caught a
black jaguar.
It chewed and busted out of my
two-by-four traps.
Later I learnt from
the Mennonites
how to build
an iron rebar trap.
I captured jaguars,
radio-collared them,
learned how to drug,
back then we didn't have vets
showing us any of this,
which wasn't good.
It was very hit or miss.
I mean, I used safe drugs
but jaguars weren't
always fully asleep.
( audience laughter )
This was difficult,
it was dangerous and
it was great.
It was my life.
This was what I was meant for.
One of the things
which I noticed right away,
in the early days is
how jaguars have a voice.
How they do talk,
they communicate
with incredible amounts of
different signals,
scratches,
scrapes, fecal deposits,
urine, feces in the scrape,
urine in the scrape,
feces next to the scrape,
they have a whole language
of how they communicate.
And I could see
jaguars probably have
the most powerful jaws
of any cat in the world.
Now that's been proven
that jaguars
per pound of animal
have the strongest jaws
of any cat in the world,
along with Clouded Leopards.
These are massively
muscled, powerful jaws.
But the most incredible thing
is what they do with that.
Jaguars kill unlike
any other cat.
All the other big cats
go for the soft, soft tissue,
go for the throat,
go for the underbelly.
Jaguars never do,
unless they miss.
Jaguars go for the skull.
Jaguars go for bone.
If it's small enough
they will get its skull
and puncture the canines
into the skull.
If it's too big,
like a 2,000-pound bull,
it goes for the
spinal vertebrae.
And punctures those canines
into the vertebrae
and snaps its neck.
Takes animals down quick.
It's a vicious, quick killer.
Eventually what I was
to realize,
the European jaguar
that had gone extinct
had never gone extinct.
It had morphed.
It had travelled
over into the New World.
And the jaguar of
the Pleistocene,
bigger, stronger had
morphed into
to a smaller, more
efficient predator.
Short limbs, low to the ground,
low center of gravity,
this animal capable of eating
anything and everything,
capable of taking down prey
with a single bite
or chewing gently
on a small bird
or an armadillo.
Its size was perfect.
Its structure was perfect,
I asked George Schaller
and the New York
Zoological Society if I
could stay longer and
I set up the world's first
Jaguar Preserve,
which ended being through
no design of mine
the first of all of the reserves
in Belize,
which is now their number one
economic import.
But the most important thing was
this could give jobs
to the Mayans who had been
killing jaguars,
now they were employed
to protect jaguar.
By the end of the 20th century
the Jaguar Preserve
had taken off.
Eco-tourism was booming
but it didn't seem to relate
to the jaguar.
The way people treated jaguars
and other animals,
the way people viewed them
was still as
a recreational outlet.
Maybe they didn't kill them,
so we played with them instead.
In 1999, I called together
all the world's jaguar experts
at a meeting in Mexico.
The point was, it wasn't many,
it was less than 25 people.
The point was to try to get
all the knowledge
of what we knew about jaguars.
Where did jaguars live
to our knowledge at that time?
In 1999 we were able to
determine about 51
what's called JCUs,
Jaguar Conservation Units.
Places where we knew
jaguars lived and bred.
By later in 2000 it went up to
almost a 100.
The point was to do triage.
That was the word of the time.
Let's take limited funding
and figure out what we can save
in different kinds of
habitat types.
So save just the highest
priority jaguar populations
in different kinds of systems.
That seemed great.
At this meeting there
were a group of geneticists.
We were gonna use DNA
and figure out how many races
of jaguar there really were.
Last line of their abstract,
which set me back on my heels
was that they said,
"There is genetic flow between
jaguar populations."
That blew me away.
I'm not even sure
they knew what they were saying.
What that meant...
they were not able to find
any races of jaguars.
None. None.
The jaguar that roamed
in Northern Mexico
up to the Southwest US,
was the same jaguar
as that in the neotropics
of Central America,
was the same jaguar
as the 300-pound animal
of the Pantanal in Brazil.
There was no other large
carnivore in the world,
still is not...
where there is no individual
races of that animal
which has been
defined through genetics.
What it meant is that these
places where we thought were
outside of jaguar range
it was all important.
Forget triage
this was the animal
of the Pleistocene,
when faced with any kind
of adversity, it moves.
It moves until it finds what
it has to find to survive.
This was the beginning of
what we call the
"Jaguar Corridor Initiative".
We were working
on the premise that
50 percent of
historic jaguar range was gone.
But the permeability model
showed that over 80 percent
of jaguar range,
while jaguars might not be able
to live through all of it,
can actually move through
80 percent
of their historic range.
Still in this day
we're working on
4.5 million square kilometers.
That's what has to be saved
to save the jaguar.
So we trained local people
on how to do interview surveys.
We trained local teams
on how to set up camera traps.
We trained ranchers
and farmers on how to,
how to identify
and pick up and collect
jaguar feces.
And we trained dogs,
usually drug sniffing dogs
on how to only sniff out
jaguar feces.
Sometimes they mess up
and it will be some other feces,
but usually only jaguar feces.
Then came all the hard part.
Fifteen years in the making.
Country by country, we would go
and do the genetic research,
it would show us that
the corridor did exist.
Now this is an
interesting thing.
Our model ended up showing us
breaks in the corridor,
based on what we knew
about jaguars.
Yet the genetics would say
that there's no breaks.
Somehow jaguars are
getting across.
One of the most
interesting areas
was that right north of
San Pedro de Sula in Honduras.
And if most of you read
the newspapers,
you'll know that that's the
murder capital of the world
because of drugs.
Now that showed up as a break
in the jaguar corridor.
But yet the genetics said
it wasn't.
So I hopped on a plane and
went to San Pedro de Sula.
And it turns out that
right outside of the town
of this city,
there is a low mountain range.
And that mountain range is
where the drug labs are.
It's where murders happen.
Local people don't
go up in there.
They're afraid they'd
get killed.
We spoke to some local people,
we got the permission,
they accompanied us
and we went up in there.
And there are jaguars roaming
through there.
The jaguars can take advantage
of that kind of thing.
So these small patches,
which we would have ignored
and would've gotten
completely cut down
are now part of the
jaguar corridor
and they're part of
what we're trying to protect.
Once we have the corridor
definitely mapped out of
where jaguars truly are walking
and we can prove it,
we then go to the government.
Once it gets signed into law
that means it's in the
country's computer system.
Anybody wanting to do the
development in the country,
having to do an
environmental impact statement,
it then pops up
if it's coming through
the jaguar corridor.
I assumed like many do
that the jaguar cultural
corridor was dead and
gone long ago.
In 2011, UNESCO declared
jaguar shamanism
to be one of the most endangered
cultural traditions
soon to be gone.
Now that's true,
looking at what used to be
but as I also learned,
about the jaguar,
what the animal was capable of,
so I also learned that
the jaguar cultural corridor
had not disappeared,
it wasn't dead.
Jaguars are still parts of
ceremony,
jaguar culture is still taught
now to school children,
they've never gone away.
But what has been
so interesting,
there are many places where
the jaguars don't exist anymore,
where they are gone.
The Mayans had a saying that
"when a jaguar dies,
a star is lost from the sky."
In these places where the jaguar
was gone,
their sky was dark...
very dark.
They want jaguars back.
But they're gone,
usually forever.
We all have a voice
but that voice has to be heard.
All of us have to
let our voice be heard,
all living things.
But for those who don't have
the exact same voice as we do,
we have to better
learn to listen
and to understand that voice.
And only through that
will we realize...
how valuable
other living things are.
Not only to our own health
and survival,
but to the health and survival
of the planet.
You have to hear that voice.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )